to call this an Insurrection for the
purposes of
disqualification uh would create a
slippery slope watch this this one's
going to blow your mind because every
now and again and I like to give credit
where credit is due every now and again
on mainstream media a sane voice is
heard now this guy's not always saying
we've played some clips of him over the
years but every now and again it breaks
through even on CNN MSNBC Etc watch this
is is Jonathan Turley he's a he's a
presidential historian if I'm not
mistaken or is he a lawyer or a
presidential historian I will find out
on the other side but take a
look well this court just handed
partisans on both sides uh the ultimate
tool to try to uh shortcut elections and
it's very very dangerous I mean this
country is a powder cake and this court
is just throwing matches at it and I
think that uh it's a real mistake but I
think that they're wrong on the law you
know January 6 was many things most of
it not good in my view was not
insurrection it was a riot that doesn't
mean that the people responsible for
that day shouldn't be held
accountable but to call this an
Insurrection for the purposes of
disqualification uh would create a
slippery slope for every state in the
Union this is a time when we actually
need democracy we need to allow the the
voters to vote we need to hear their
decision and the court here just said
you're not going to get that uh in
Colorado we're not going to let you vote
for Donald Trump no and you know you
could dislike Trump you can believe he's
responsible for January 6 but this isn't
the way to do it I mean it is you know
for people that say they're trying to
protect democracy this is hands down the
most
anti-democratic opinion I've seen in my
lifetime you guys know I'm not above
correcting myself that was not sanity
breaking through on CNN or MSNBC my bad
that was Fox News I guess it's not that
surprising that they brought on turle
turle is a lawyer and a professor by the
way uh but of course everything he said
there was right the very people who
purport to be defending democracy from
Donald Trump are the people who are
taking the front runner out or hoping to
take the front runner out of the race
that is not protecting democracy and
even if again you thought that what
happened on January 6th was really
really bad and you thought Trump had
something to do with it if we just start
saying well the will of the people
should just be ignored
right and certain States will just
decide who people can vote for right so
let's say let's say they get away with
this let's say Colorado actually gets
away with this for some reason it
doesn't get to the Supreme Court or the
Supreme Court doesn't reverse it if it
does get there what precedent have We
Now set well any state on any given
moment can be like all right we're just
not going to put that guy on the ballot
what what would stop California the next
time from saying you know they have a
highly partisan Court they have a highly
partisan you know system from top to
bottom what would them stop them from
saying all right we're not going to put
Republicans on the ballot anymore I mean
not the Republicans ever win anything
there but you get the point like once we
do this you're just sort of removing any
validity from the system and that is a
huge huge
problem